did you know that in part three of
Attack on Titan Aaron literally killed
his own grandparents way back in season
3 we found out that Dr Yeager and his
wife live inside the Liberia internment
Zone and when Aaron visited the Zone
during the final season he actually sat
down and spoke to his granddad however
since then his grandparents were both
locked up in a prison cell presumably
because Zeke betrayed the warriors with
no way to escape they could only hug
each other as the rumbling approach but
what's crazy is that before they were
trampled I don't think they ever fully
realized that Aaron was their grandson